if we wanted to buy some shares in this
what do we do well very simply as soon
as the initial offering opens and I'll
just bring you back to another one okay
so this is our offering that's happening
this Friday our III for ATS ciri
speciality that's right so it's this is
the most rare of the v8 Ferraris from
the 1990s they only made a hundred of
these really spectacular example
awarding v12s and everything well they
always meet ya VA Ferraris are always
the they made a series of that it you
know in terms of the rear engine v8
Ferrari Scot yes and so there's only a
hundred thirty-eight thousand that's
right and this is a deal like for
example the as the community develops we
were able to move a deal like this in a
matter of a few hours what's the minimum
investment one share and in this car
that'll be two thousand shares so about
five hundred bucks no no no mm mm chairs
it's not 200 that's right now so sixty
seventy dollars yeah Wow
yeah so this is like micro-invest my
grandma invested and we didn't we have
we have a range of investors across the
spectrum but for us it was very
important is no velvet ropes right we
didn't want to take something that was
for billionaires and make it available
to millionaires we wanted to take
something that was available to was that
was now available to everybody so remove
all velvet ropes especially so here
we're gonna click on what we'll hit
explore to start yep explore and then
once you're in here again similar to the
last one you could work your way through
the legal dollar bill transactions right
the story the investment thesis the
photos and videos and then ultimately
the timeline is every data point that
we've collected on the history of this
asset right and then once this this deal
goes live essentially what will happen
is we run what's an initial offering
very much like an IPO during that period
of time we raise money from our
community and those dollars go to
actually acquire the asset on behalf of
the investors in the deal amazing yeah
and so people can pay with a credit card
or wire transfer right now we do connect
your bank account is super seamless but
we we don't do credit cards just yet
we're working on because the SEC doesn't
want people putting this on their credit
card so it's send a signal that it's not
an investment it's more like it's really
not the SEC was more we didn't we didn't
really want to make it where it just
felt funny to have people you know maybe
taking you know 20% interest
put their money you know it's something
that's not gonna grow at 20 percent yeah
yeah just didn't didn't feel exactly
moral but you know there's other ways
like in our gifting flow for example if
I wanted a gift you a share that you'd
be able to use a credit card for that
type of opportunity what is your
commitment let's say this is a hundred
thousand dollar purchase of the hundred
thousand going and how much would you be
us we would represent between two and
ten percent of every deal Wow
yeah and you tell people what percent
you are and then do they read into that
oh you're putting ten percent into this
you believe in it more than the one you
put two percent into we don't and and
you know we tend to try and leave as
much open for our community as possible
we just tried to leave that flexibility
so that we can we could play a different
role depending on the deal ah so if it
didn't fill up you could fill up the
rest exactly now are you buying these on
contingency where you have an agreement
to buy it if you clear market what
happens if you don't clear market
exactly and so in most cases we're
taking option agreements so I don't
really like the idea of consignment I
feel like it doesn't align incentives
appropriately so if we're going to take
a deal with one of our you know one of
our suppliers will usually put something
down to make sure they know that we have
skin in the game as well in the event it
didn't fill we've yet to miss one in
terms of we're very deliberate about you
know running our deals in terms of their
investing as well as their marketability
on the platform so we try to be really
deliberate about when and how we bring
things to market but in the event one
didn't fill it would go back to the
owner what's the deal what do you get
out of this for us well one we get we
get the opportunity to put these
investments together we take a small
piece of the look of the deal the
liquidity from the seller and compared
to like for example if they took what
does that mean a so we tell ourselves it
for a hundred thousand you know my
percent a little less but yes that
that's about right percent something in
that range typically yes and
comparatively to what that seller would
pay to a dealer or an auction house it's
substantially more favored what are the
auction houses when I watch that stuff
on TV usually around 20 percent 20
percent hey and that's for cars if
you're in other asset classes could be
upwards of 30 percent so it's like an
app store vague yeah yeah seems
reasonable if they put together a giant
auction and get all the people buyers in
the room absolutely because you'll be
doing a lot of work yeah all you have to
think about is would I be able to sell
this car for the same price or
would they get more than 20% Feeny in a
different situation correct so in most
cases I think the answer be yes depends
on what you have ah
so if the things really in demand you
would just fly off the shelves that's
exciting to buy or medium that's exactly
right yeah so if you own a beautiful
modern masterpiece of a house on the
hottest street in town you could just do
for sale by owner just like any other
asset that's right yes so how many
people participate in the if you were to
average the last three deals
how many investors were there on average
in each deal in some of our smaller
deals it's usually a few hundred
investors and some of our larger ones
it's upwards of a thousand thousand yeah
and it cost you $20,000 to set up the
legal work for this aisle absolutely not
no with the way we have it structured
it's more like you couldn't get like a
shelf registration and so that means
Shalford sort of like when you know when
you take a company public you want to
put additional security is on that shelf
so we've got it set up very templatized
where each time we put a like like kind
thing on it it amortizes the cost over a
larger base of deals got it yeah you
created like a series exact documents
for these kind of funds yes and then and
they're not funds they're actually all
independent securities and they're all
independent from one another so if for
example one deal went bad for some
reason that would in no way impact any
of the other deals Scott if nobody
wanted Lamborghinis anymore that's right
there was some they all Hawks ik reason
that they all have is that they all have
their own securities that they all have
their own cin numbers they all have
their own cap table depending on the
deal and then you have to spend 500
bucks a thousand bucks a year
maintaining them under a thousand okay
so you got if you hold this for twenty
year period twenty thousand dollars in
the kind of like admin costs plus the
ten or fifteen thousand in wire costs
and setup costs this is about thirty
thousand dollars to hold it for two
decades or twenty thousand for a decade
if you held it for a decade it would be
less than twenty thousand so we've got
it down you know down to hundreds the
reason I bring this up is you know I do
a similar thing with syndicates Jason
syndicate formerly on Angeles we moved
off Angeles because I get back to the
Vig why give them in their case they
asked for 25 we were getting ten yep but
why give them the vague
sense and so you have to buy an asset
that is in order for it to be you want
it to be less than 10% costs yes
absolutely or else you have to spend the
first year or two recruiting yeah yes
and and we're not spending anywhere near
10% cost to get you set up what is the
vision for how long you hold these
because that's the other thing I don't
understand you just hold it forever and
have people trade in and out of it it
depends on the asset and what's really
good about this if we don't want to
publish a district holding period right
so in these types of illiquid assets the
signaling risk in the sense of if you
want to buy something the price goes up
if you want to sell something the price
goes down and a lot of that gets lost in
terms you lose a lot of your sort of
upside in that signaling so for us
everything's always for sale and so
we're always fielding inbound offers to
actually we call them like takeover
offers to take the asset back private
right got it yes and so we're getting
inbound offers on a daily basis for all
of the the assets on the on that so you
have Jerry what if Jerry Seinfeld's
former cars on there just if somebody
came on board to buy Jerry Seinfeld's
former what is it a Porsche
yes 89 Porsche speedster yeah so if
somebody wanted to buy his Porsche
speedster and I had bought shares in it
yes and somebody offers 150% then when I
bought it am i forced to sell is it
dragged along with the group you makes
the decision so the decisions ultimately
made by our Advisory Board of experts we
tried to keep it as Democratic as
possible and they make the decision on
our behalf we couldn't run it as a true
vote because again the costs of actually
running that vote for what is
essentially a public company yeah would
outstrip the value the right of the
actual deal so what we do instead is
poll the user base and then leverage
data right we've got this secondary
market where transactions are happening
which show relative supply and demand
and the sort of sentiment of the
investment community over a period of
time so that indication plus polling the
actual audience of investors the
syndicate allows us to get a good
temperature for whether or not it's a
good time to sell